this movie is uh hilarious really really
hilarious and I think I heard a lot of
you laughing at it
uh two
um sometimes people say that your
sophomore film outing is even more
difficult to do than than your first did
you find this one to be more difficult
to make than your first home it was uh
yeah I think it was more difficult to
make it physically just because it was
bigger in scope and scale but I think in
terms of like that sophomore slump thing
I feel like people are often referring
to like it's harder to get it made like
to like go find the right producers in
the right studio and whatnot and I feel
like I don't know because we were trying
to push bottoms before Shiva baby was
even made like it kind of it didn't come
seamlessly but it I don't know it worked
out it was harder to make it though in
that it was just more people and so yeah
so tell us about
um creating this you you co-wrote it
with Rachel Senate who plays PJ in the
movie yeah and was the lead in gym baby
um tell us about that what's so what's
your relationship with Rachel are you
it's like how when did you meet each
other when did you start working
together I met Rachel when she was in
the short film first of a baby that um
the feature is based on which I made in
University and she was in school at the
same time at NYU
um and we enjoyed working with each
other so much on the short and I could
just tell she was like so ambitious and
so funny and she's a hilarious stand-up
comedian and there she was and so I just
saw her like with her goals and going to
like open Microsoft all the time and
um I told her I wanted to make she have
a baby a feature and she was like that's
awesome like when and how do you want to
do that and like it sort of asked me a
million like organizational questions
and then asked if I had any other ideas
and I told her my one comedy idea which
was a version of this and then um asked
her if she wanted to be PJ and write it
with me and she said yes and that was
six years ago and then we wrote bottoms
at the same time as I was writing to
show the baby the future wow yeah yeah
that's amazing yeah
so it's really interesting because
um you're Canadian and I assume went to
high school in Canada at the us but
Rachel is from the US is Canadian High
School like very similar in very many
ways to U.S High School like not in this
way no
I feel like this was like my idea of
like what I thought American had
but combined with Rachel's small town
American High School experience yeah you
know what I mean so if I feel like they
came at it from two wonderfully
different perspectives so where did
Rachel go to high school what was her
model she went to high school in a very
small town in Connecticut her town is
like very idyllic and cute and like not
run by like football players right
um but she was able to sort of like
educate me a little bit on like on the
American High School experience that I
didn't understand sort of the
um intricacies of
um uh but yeah but she had but like she
was from a town that had a lot more like
Spirit you know what I mean than what I
can sort of relate to
so both of the films that you have have
made are sex themed and I wanted to ask
you
um kind of a Hardball question right off
the top which and this is kind of a fig
piece so go with me here you guys I was
something that I read on Instagram the
other day uh Karina Longworth who does
the you must remember this podcast have
you ever heard of it yeah yeah so she
just did an erotic 80s series and she
wrote on Instagram that uh some of their
posts are uh for her erotic 80s series
are being censored by Instagram
these are screenshots from films that
have existed from the 1980s since the
1980s
and she made a post that basically uh
I'm paraphrasing here but the post on
Instagram was you know I get asked a lot
if I think that sex
that that we're
in the US not really making this kind of
film erotic films that we made in the
1980s and and why and she was like to me
this is a good example right here the
the fact that Instagram is now censoring
something like this
and sort of like asking the questions
around why is this censored now like
what's going on like what if there are
isn't less sex
themed films and sex in films is it an
organized
conspiracy I don't want to say
conspiracy but is it an organized effort
by somebody so I just wanted to ask you
do you feel like you've had a lot of
pushback on your film making your films
because of their sexual themes
and you feel like did you did you feel
like you had pushed about like you had
to fight with for them or that you
people were trying to censor you in any
way making earphones
I didn't feel that anyone was trying to
censor me who was in on making the movie
like or both movies like in terms of our
producers or financiers or Studio like
everyone who signed up to make the movie
with me understood the movie we were
making and both of them were very sexual
in their own way
um but in terms of like other
collaborators or people that could
potentially be helping us
um uh yeah we ran into definitely people
who are folks who didn't who found
Bottoms in particular too offensive to
be associated with
um like we we shot in New Orleans and
there were a lot of locations that are
either owned by the church or the parish
and
um uh we lost a lot of locations once
people sort of figured out what the
movie was about
um or even just like product placement
stuff like not that our movie was riding
on like writing or dying on like I don't
know like iPhones or whatever but like
uh every almost every single corporation
that like waves their pride flag in June
said the movie was too offensive to be
associated with
um and yeah that was
sort of I kind of like I was just so
naive I think I remain naive when it
comes to making sexual movies or gay
movies or whatever it is and I think
that's a good thing like I think that I
just try to keep being like everyone
wants to see this and or there's a few
there's an audience for this somewhere
and so I'll just keep making it until
you know people tell me not to but um
yeah I don't know
um thankfully though like our support
like the people making it like I said
which is never like the studio was like
wait a second actually this movie's too
sexual you know what I mean like they
they bought it they understood it and
they let me do what I wanted
um
uh did you think that you were being
rejected because it's queer and sexual
or just purely the sexual just the fact
that it was sexual at all I think queer
and female yeah yeah I think that um I
think it would have been a little
different if it was like a super bad or
American Pie if it was like two boys
trying to lose their virginities but
yeah so I I think so but no one was like
this is too gay they were just like it's
okay but like it's like yeah we're gonna
we're gonna yeah
no
um so let's talk about your actors
talked about Rachel uh let's talk about
IO how long have you know we've known IO
Rachel and I since NYU days so also like
seven years
um her and Rachel used to do like these
sketches together at NYU that weirdly
our DP Maria also shot before I even met
Maria
um where they Rachel would write them
and get all her comedian friends to be
in them um some of them don't exist
anymore
um but uh like they've been taking down
but they work together a bunch and I I
was always just been so hilarious and
they did stand up together all the time
and it's just so funny now like she's
had such a rise and I'm so proud of her
as her friend and collaborator
um but like I don't know we were all
just like friends and I was like a
writer's assistant for years and then
like was in writer's rooms and
um you know she's an incredible
improviser and and a wonderful actor
um I feel like the part that she plays
on the bear is so different and that's
where I first saw her
and so in this part I was just like wow
she's so funny yeah so like she has that
gift of comic time they both do so just
they're just on it
and
um
I don't know I just think it's great
she's getting to show her chops yeah
something serious and something that's
just this crazy funny was so was it
mostly scripted did you allow them to do
improvisation okay definitely allowed
Rachel and I have to do improv to a
faults where I was like starting to get
confused
um but it was so much fun to watch them
and especially IO she she prefers improv
I don't think she ever like read a line
sort of on the first take that as
scripted and then I would be like okay
like can we can we try to get it I
scripted she'd be like fine but um yeah
uh I kind of had to because I just knew
that it was going to be so much better
if I let them have that freedom but it
was scary to do improv I feel like
uh
what about um
uh Marsha and Lynch
who didn't he do an improv show murdered
Netflix yeah yes that's where I watched
him and is that how you got the idea to
do I didn't get the idea Alana the head
of Orion it was her idea she saw an
article that was like basically I think
it was like deadline or whatever it was
like he was funny or adapted like all
the other comedians on that show and um
I watched it and then yeah I agreed with
her that we should we should have him in
Bottoms and
um I didn't know who he was before
um but uh I mean I thought it would be
so cool to like have someone completely
different from a different world yeah
different industry like do this it was
so funny he is phenomenally funny and I
really loved him as the teacher um you
know and then even the the kid that we
love to hate uh who plays the the head
football player Jeff yeah Nicholas he's
great yeah he's fantastic Nick he's he's
so good his whole like yeah
yeah he's so good he's played like a
version of like literally Prince
Charming or the hot guy like or the
brooding sort of like romantic lead in
teen movies like now a couple times in
different ways and so I feel like I
think he had fun sort of making fun of
that he's done that a bunch and this
this was more of a silly version of that
exact same character that he's done but
he was so good yeah so where did you
actually shoot this New Orleans in New
Orleans yeah was it at a real high
school or Junior High yeah it was
because we were shooting it in football
season which was like the worst decision
ever I don't know why and me again not
knowing
anything about how that Works in this
country
didn't prepare for that so we it ended
up being a concoction of like a
University gym a random parking lot
somewhere uh I don't actually think we
shot in a high school at all I think we
we found like a basically abandoned like
Elementary School that we like it was
almost like a stage and we used the
hallways and created a classroom brought
in lockers
um we tried our best we toured many high
schools there and then ever I don't know
it was just it didn't work out
um and none of the private schools
wanted us um because they were all
Catholic um uh but yeah so no no high
schools actually it was like seven
different places
well it all works
really well thank you I kept looking at
it and being like
but then also like all school it it
shocks me it feels like our education
system is is one of the few things that
has not changed drastically in this
country like if you could if I go to a
high school or a junior high which I
don't very often but I feel like it all
feels so much the same as when I was in
full in like the late 80s and 90s well
we try to find locations that had
elements of like a Timeless feel like I
and I I kind of would put my foot down
on it like I really wanted Old Brick in
the building the way that like I would
see it in like Japanese movies and I
really wanted wooden bleachers in the
gym I didn't want like modern shiny
whatever
um and and I I so we sort I'm glad
you're saying that yeah yeah
so that was yeah that was another
question I was going to ask is were you
inspired by any other teen movies the
John Hughes movies were like what was
popular when I was a teenager I went to
a lot of giant I went to the first run
that's I'm telling you how old I am
right
yeah definitely each team movies
I I loved teen movies like I've seen
every single
time period of tea movies that I could I
mean when I was growing up it was like
the Y2K like can't be movies like and
the rom-coms of the late 90s and early
2000s so like bring it on and and and 10
things ahead about you and she's all
that and like But I'm a Cheerleader and
um you know uh sugar and spice and
jawbreakers like what dog drop it
gorgeous like those were that was like
the moment um all the Kirsten Dunst
movies like strike and Dick
um and then um I I mean I watch you know
I went back and discovered like John
Hughes and like Heathers and you know
like all that stuff and then I think for
this with the Timeless feel like I
Revisited also like more like classic
like Americana movies like Greece and
American Graffiti and I don't know other
movies that I I was trying to just take
inspiration from these stereotypes that
have been created since that time period
of like the jock and the cheerleader and
sort of try to put our queer characters
in this Zone that has existed for so
long
how do you
one of the things I marveled at in this
movie is the best is the balance of
having you know your protagonists are
queer and yet they're so messed with by
everybody in this High School including
the principal
how do you feel like when you're cutting
this you sort of balance the humor so
that it doesn't get too offensive
towards
like they're not too too shed on they're
still I mean they're very showed on what
was it like one of my favorite lines is
um
uh the
untalented and unattractive queers
please come to the Earth how did you
think of things like that what what do
you like
what made you feel like this
in this world of this movie
these queers would be like kind of shit
on it
um I think we wanted to make it clear
that like they're losers not because
they're gay but because they're like not
like I think like the way you can be gay
at least like when I was in high school
and accepted is if you were like super
talented and hot do you know what I mean
like as the theater okay so the more
shit on because they're not talented
yeah because they're basic is you know
like I feel like you have to be the
exceptional gay in high school or in the
world in order to be accepted so it's
the you're not a cheerleader or a jock
so you're
that and that's very traditional High
School yeah yeah I don't know I think
that we just wanted to show that they're
being shut on because they're losers you
know they just happen to be gay yeah
okay
um did anybody have a question that they
wanted to ask
I'll do all the questions if you want
did you ever go to juvie for real really
do you know anybody that went to Judy no
and Rachel said I go to Jamie she didn't
but she used to do theater in high
school and they would like travel her
little theater troop to the Judy's to
like perform for them well I guess I
don't know really yeah is that where you
got the idea of the juvie I don't know
no I don't think so
um no I think I don't know how that we
were just thinking about like where
where somewhere that they could lie
about being that big they think is
badass or something I don't know
um so one of my favorite scenes is um
uh Josie's lesbian Mentor
played by Punky Johnson yeah can you
tell me about this amazing thing like
where did you get the idea for this yeah
it just comes out of nowhere and I was
like it's perfect
I wish I could just be like I thought of
this out of nowhere and I just thought
this would be such a fun Cameo for like
a cool queer actor but actually there
was like this whole other storyline that
the movie had that got cut that punky's
character had a bigger role in that the
beginning of the movie actually was
supposed to take place at this weird
camp for corny girls where it wasn't
like inversion therapy but it was like a
military kind of camp where you got sent
if you were like too horny just a girl
oh my God okay Punky ran the camp
um and it was like only a few scenes but
audience like test screenings people
were like I don't know what's going on
and the lie was that there went to juvie
when really they went to this like crazy
Camp so there was this whole sort of
backstory
um and that's where punky's character
was established and then we tried to
salvage this camp in so many ways and we
kept on being like how does punky's
character make any sense like if we have
to get rid of this and then eventually
we were like I think we just we we say
like that she was her babysitter or her
Mentor or whatever and we just got to
keep the cameo in there and like make it
work and I just kept on being like Oh my
God No One's Gonna Get this this is so
random but um then I thought the movie's
pretty random
I'm glad you thought so I mean basically
all she does is just walk up on her like
in her trailer and I never had any
questions about who the fuck is this
yeah like what's this doing in here it
was just
also completely hilarious including the
last part of it were Punk he's like
and I was like I didn't I just didn't
understand it
so much about I think just felt like so
spontaneous so are you do you feel like
I mean I don't want you to put yourself
in a box
but do you feel like comedy is where
you want to be and you want to stay no I
don't think so not that I I'd love to do
a comedy again but I just hope to do
something in every genre yeah yeah
speaking of do you have something ready
to go for your next not ready to go the
way that like bottoms is ready to go
um but uh I have other ideas yeah things
in progress yeah yeah yeah
you're not gonna give us a clue I don't
I could I could tell you I mean I have
other ideas I'm working on but I don't
know which one would be next so yeah
yeah it's like a lesbian rock opera I've
yeah I maybe I mean I want to do other
like a horror movie and like a Sci-Fi
yeah totally I think what you're doing
not just to stay in comedy but I just
want to say I think that what you're
doing is hard to pull up comedy's hard
to pull off I really believe the comedy
is
tougher to do and tougher it's tougher
to make something that you'll let people
will laugh out loud so congratulations
thank you I wish you have a baby and
this are both hilarious and wonderful I
think that this is such a fresh
it just feels fresh
um I'm wondering what you think
people's take away from this will be oh
I'm wondering
what you think this film says about a
queer people's position like in the
world because you know like in the John
Hughes films that I grew up with
there was no mention of anybody being
queer besides someone being called fagot
at one point in the movie and then that
was about it right we weren't
acknowledged we were invisible pretty
much
that's pretty much my high school
experience too if anything queer or any
person who was queer did come it was
kind of squashed nobody talked about it
nobody came out wondering what you're
saying with this movie of what you think
the position of queers is now because
we're in a strange place in this country
with it really
yeah I mean honestly like I I really
that I completely hear what you're
saying I think I wanted to make
something more like queer people could
watch themselves and not have to think
too hard about their identity do you
know what I mean and just like just see
themselves and like be entertained like
just see themselves and laugh and not
have to think to
deeply about like what does this mean or
whatever like I I think I just wanted to
make something stupid you know I just
feel like I'm a lesbian and I'm horny
too exactly exactly yeah like that's it
like literally all right the takeaway is
like as dumb as like we I don't know
like I you wanted to be like I don't
think if anyone has any smarter thoughts
about sort of what this means that's
amazing but that definitely didn't come
from
did you see any of the crazy weirdo sex
comedies of the 80s like last American
Virgin and Porky's and I did it you guys
I would want to catch some of them on TV
but no this is hard to watch it reminded
me like be mad because that's all that
those comedies were about was people
trying to get laid Yeah no I think I was
more influenced by what was influenced
by that uh which was like American Pie
and super bad yeah
but but yes everyone has referred to
Porky's like so many times okay
um no no everyone keeps saying porkies
I'm like okay yeah
there's a glory hole in it it was my
first exposure to emporial
I didn't even know I was being exposed
to something clear like 12 years old uh
Mrs Bell breaker
um
um the movie was such a fun ride and I
thought it really it balanced out not
getting too woke and just like letting
people experiences people be queer I was
curious what made you decide for PJ to
not get the girl in the end
um uh well thank you for saying that
um I think I think one we were like
I think that's too easy or something I
mean I think that like we debated for so
long like
do we need to explain what Isabelle and
Britney's sexualities are like so that
we know that they're not trying to like
turn them or something and then we were
like no like that's so like Millennial
like let's just like let everyone
breathe in their sexualities and
whatever
um and just like you don't need to
answer all these questions and anyway I
mean I have experiences with queer
baiting and with lots of you know and I
think so many queer women have
experiences with straight girls for I
don't know pretending to kind of be
queer a little or whatever learning or
um
what can you be talking about so I think
that was funneled into it and also I
think it was just like we didn't want it
to be so like la la la like and then
they both get the girl and and that
check mark we wanted to do something
slightly unexpected so
um yeah I think that that's just where
that came about
I I feel like
you know you're only two films in and I
expect that you're you know gonna be
many more films in and uh I don't you
know 20 years down the road we'll talk
again you're gonna be like 50 films in
but the accomplishment that you've made
with
uh this many films at the age that you
are still really young and is is a huge
accomplishment and I'm just wondering
what
um
I'm imagining that it's been very hard
to be an indie filmmaker I'm just
wondering what it is that you
use her inspiration because we have a
lot of usually have a lot of members
that are
um Indie filmmakers trying to make their
first trying to make their second or
just trying to stay in there what do you
use for inspiration do you have like a
group of people around you that could be
going in
yeah well thank you for saying that
um I think honestly it sounds so cheesy
and like cliche but like it's working
with other people like young people or
young filmmakers or people young in
their careers like who I feel
equally invested in you and in
themselves and like believe this sounds
so like cheesy but it's so hard to make
movies and it's so hard to make Indies
like your first one and you just like
need people who are gonna be as crazy as
you like and like jump off like a
building with you and like literally put
all your energy and time toward yeah
trying to get money or trying to get
casting or whatever it is that's your
first few steps and Rachel was that for
me
um and I don't think I would have like a
fiction said that about you too it's
interesting in interviews you guys say
the same thing about each other yeah so
are each other's
support system it's yeah you need it I
think like I just think you you can't
just you can't do it alone like you
really can't it's like too much so
whether you know and my producers on
chip a baby also sort of threw in and
gave gave a lot of their energy and time
and and were I went to film school with
them and were you want to be with a
bunch of people who want to prove
themselves and and doing it together is
kind of yeah the only way
yeah and also it's so interesting
it was so interesting to see this and
realize that all three of you knew each
other you Rachel and IO and I was like
wow there's like a community
uh filmmakers and artists going on we
were all working on each other's things
yeah supporting each other I just love
that like the safety Brothers started
out in a collective that was called red
bucket and it was a bunch of filmmakers
that would all work on each other's
projects and that's how they started out
and I I know collectives don't often
work out but like you know communities
of artists it feels like it feels like
there must have been a lot of people in
those few years of NYU that you were
there that were all that are of all kind
of like
come together to work on stuff together
yeah definitely and and now there's I
think a handful of us from my year at
least that have done really well like
Kate Zohar we just had our second movie
Itself by called close to me or this
closeness
um uh both her movies were with movie
um it was up here and
um it feels really really cool yeah I
mean and and Molly Gordon didn't go to
NYU but she met IO through Rachel and I
um she was in Shiva baby and then I was
in Theater Camp which just came out this
summer and then also Molly acts in the
bear and so it's really cool to be like
part of this community that's like
coming up at the same time yeah yeah
it's very exciting yeah I admire it I'm
gonna admire about all of you so thank
you quick question yep when did
Elizabeth Banks get involved in this
um Elizabeth got involved
um uh in April 2020 when Shiva baby was
supposed to go to South by Southwest but
it didn't and so people kind of heard
about it because it was supposed to go
but no one could see it because of covid
it was like the first big world event or
one of the big one of those like is this
the real kind of thing so if I was
canceled um and uh uh she and and her
producer Elizabeth Allison small watch
of a baby
um on like a link that was being sent
around
um and uh and then we sent them the
script for bottoms and they just like
jumped on board we'd sent it to so many
other producers before who said no or
didn't get it but um Elizabeth and and
her husband Max and Allison just like
were so enthusiastic and and wanted to
make it with us so she came on pretty
quick this reminds me a little bit of
like Pitch Perfect which is really yeah
yeah
totally I could see why she'd want to
get attached to this yeah she's she's
done so many comedies and and on her own
but yeah like that's a franchise that
like also kind of has camp and a weird
tone and yeah you know and she's so
supportive of working with female
directors and um you know
um yeah so that definitely played a part
in sort of understanding like oh this
will be the right partner because she
understands like making stuff with all
women and where it's weird you know
um so when when does this come out it's
this week it comes out Friday here
um New York San Francisco and uh Boston
and then the next week September 1st it
comes out everywhere else is should a
baby being re-released yeah yeah
why that deserves
[Applause]
it's been out it's been for the last
couple weekends
um in a handful of cities it's like two
screenings at like one theater and like
each city
um but yeah it's it's had a little
moment
it's fantastic Utopia is awesome that's
our distributor they just were like oh
Bottom's coming out cool like let's
bring to it back so yeah a little
feature yeah it will feature exactly
yeah well thank you so much for taking
the time yeah thank you girls thank you
for watching it here yeah thank you
[Music]